hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander
today we're checking out the best vines
of june part 8 for 2015 fine compilation
this was sent to us let's check it out
how are you making scrambled eggs
fertilized okay well hey what's up girl
yeah
that's on me girl shut up freak up I got
way too much on my mental alert you
ready why kick her just kidding thank
you I'm a girl but me and my girlfriend
love each other guys [ __ ] kiss and
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] hot I'm a guy a me
and my boyfriend [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
your granny how do you like that oh
don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
hey who's ready for my birthday getting
ready to do something to know I'm
running for president seven eight nine
[ __ ] rabbit baby I'm in the kitchen
cooking pies baby is he a good artist so
realistic
well stop bitching who are you like a
chameleon never you anything yeah let's
just do we I swear to God yeah I swear I
stole Shh
that's the restriction please back up
keep that book around wait you're messy
beat you ate my food and beat let's see
we get a selfie yeah uh do me a favor
yeah get that [ __ ] up tonight
so there's purple on there yeah Purple's
actually my favorite what
oh hi gun Feltes feathers really nice
Oh be quiet I'm doing a toast for [ __ ]
that don't really mean [ __ ] that's why
y'all be doing the most you see that are
you serious
hey what's a [ __ ] says he'll my
driver's license their name's Evan
[ __ ] oh my gosh you're a friend of
where'd you learn how to drive get the
[ __ ] off me
Oh what is yeah but the kid that's on
the hot seat
seriously gay for Ruby Rose gay for Ruby
like seriously gay for Ruby Rose really
gave me my corn on the cob God check in
with me with me and do your job [ __ ]
a [ __ ] I'm gonna watch Oh
kid's gonna play with Barney oh my god
oh yeah
camera cut sorry guys that's my jam oh
my god oh my god he's gonna say stress
words huh hi welcome to Chile I don't
understand why you're dating Danny he's
so immature
yeah but I think I could change you want
to take a nap
Danny okay take a nap right there oh
nothing you see she said um Christy let
him go where's my money bro
first thanks for a really refreshing new
Bruce LeBaron labor go depression of a
heartbroken seagull yeah I got him in my
sights
oh my god fake timberlands take the shot
whoa it's actually your head okay maybe
all right story time suddenly the two
felt the urge to get up and dance and
then the my guy joined the pack whoa
yeah hi BAE I'm home alone okay so you
stay there and I'll stay here doesn't
that sound like a plan
their way did you hear that gay marriage
is legal now in the u.s. really yep you
want to get married yes sir
let's go little Wayne's a genius dick
everybody at Hollywood's it birthday I
tell my birthday isn't until late July
[ __ ] don't remember what time I stabbed
you got it framed heritage honey
how many you got - mama stop your girls
the [ __ ] world it's real rich coming
from a [ __ ] [ __ ] my sister like that
she's a [ __ ] she's gonna I had such a
horrible day today are you listening to
me i pregnant
seriously Susan grow some balls all
right
mmm oh my god I did it you did there she
is my love I come for you now girl this
place is got Wi-Fi it's so fast right
one molar what the [ __ ] did you get that
I brought it with me
hey wait rain hey Susan could you pass
me that home care yourself [ __ ] yo I got
these on thin ice
Archer you're my only best girl
oh please put your eye on her
yeah where's the baby making your woman
happy is pretty easy you gotta do is
rubber but sometimes called pretty most
guys have trouble with the last one
you'll get it don't [ __ ] other women
excuse me miss is this yours hey when I
got with air conditioning and vehicles
anyway I think it only has two settings
rubber nipple or sweaty I'll scrub
Billy's actually an order to stop you
Billy I paint pictures of death using my
own blood isn't me creative I'm ordering
PT you want anything
you're on a diet it's my cheat day said
yesterday was your cheeto no yesterday I
cheated on you once I hide every special
cuz it's over oh what's wrong with your
computer I was ready to watch 20 more
vintage for money yeah we both have
lines I have a vine that I've been
posting a little bit more often than
usual lately so check it out yeah the
vine trains awesome I keep watching
these because I keep loving the
inspiration I'm gonna make some vines
right now so check us out online yeah I
guess this video has become a promo
video for my own vine not my vine you
need to do more hereby before I can
properly promote your vine you know
remember when we used to have sexual
attention correction removin I used to
have sexual tension yes I feel like
without that you don't care as much I
don't care as much well um my last video
on the real redux sorry goodbye Sally if
you guys are new to the channel though
you can check out salamander Sally's
channel it's a great channel that has a
vlog that she recently posted that
features hurt
I can't talk right now she has a vlog
that she recently posted that features
her with Howie Mandel and in one of
these vines they were using something
that I used in a vlog to watch it and I
know
we'll find out yeah it's a fun game for
you oh yeah you can subscribe to the
reel rejects too you could do that if
you want and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and like I
said vine follow us because what we're
really trying to do is get product
placement we want product placement for
things such as the [ __ ] these called
hair clip hair clips hair clips are
great oh haha hair clip you know where
I'm going with this live a boot cut to
the joke pubes
you can totally hair clip your pubes
because sometimes it gets so bushy down
there cuz you know a woman might like it
you know I've actually met quite a good
amount of women who are like I don't
like writing my guy if he's completely
shaved because it actually hurts so they
prefer there to be a little bit of hair
um you can't go all the way down your
boyfriend cause of how big his dick is
though so you don't know what that
problems like or Canyon is it hurt well
I'm talking to you you do oh my god but
yeah this helps your boobs